Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我和我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊共同发起的“迈向经常性收入挑战”。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. What is bipolar disorder?
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。什么是双相障碍？
What does it look like? How do you treat it? How might you recognise it? And how do you learn to live with it or live with somebody you love who might have it? My guest today has bipolar disorder himself and we are answering all of these questions and more. I hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent. I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. I love introducing you to topics that help you to learn more about key clinical areas, which might be of significance for you in your clinical area of work or for those that you love or care about. Today, my guest and I
它是什么样子的？如何治疗？你该如何识别它？你又该如何学会与它共处，或者与你所爱且患有此病的人共处？我今天的嘉宾本人就患有双相障碍，我们将一起回答所有这些问题以及更多内容。希望这对你有所帮助。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我是一名合格的临床心理学家。我喜欢向大家介绍一些主题，帮助你们更多地了解关键的临床领域，这些领域可能对你的临床工作，或者对你所爱、所关心的人具有重要意义。今天，我和我的嘉宾
are taking a deep dive into bipolar disorder, and it is a completely brilliant episode. Even though I've been qualified for many years now, I learned so many useful things from talking to my guest, Sam. So I hope that you will find the same. I'll look forward to catching up with you on the other side of this. Hi, I just want to welcome our guest for today, Sam Swidinski. Hi, Sam. Hi, lovely to be on. Lovely to have you here. And thank you so much for reaching out. I'm really excited to talk with you and to kind of bring information about your specialist subject, this is not Mastermind, but which is bipolar disorder. So it's lovely to have you here. No, it's good. I mean, any opportunity that I can
将深入探讨双相障碍，这是一期非常精彩的节目。尽管我已经从业多年，但与我的嘉宾萨姆交谈后，我学到了很多有用的知识。希望你们也能有同样的收获。节目结束后，我期待与你们再次交流。嗨，我想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾萨姆·斯维丁斯基。你好，萨姆。你好，很高兴能参加节目。很高兴你能来。非常感谢你主动联系我。我真的很兴奋能和你交谈，并带来关于你专业领域的信息——虽然这不是《最强大脑》，但你的专业领域是双相障碍。所以很高兴你能来。不，这很好。我的意思是，任何机会
have to be able to talk about this important topic is a great pleasure. So thank you. Yeah, so just to help our audience to kind of get a feel for who you are and why you're talking to us about bipolar disorder could you give yourself a little intro? Yeah I mean I'm Sam so the reason why I care so much about bipolar disorder is because of my own lived experience so when I was 18 I was, but it took a few years to be able to get that diagnosis in the first place, which caused some troubles during my teen years. But I was very, very fortunate to meet people that took me under their wing and were able to help me in terms of within the mental health field. And because of that, I'm very, very grateful. And I guess gratitude for them made me realize
只要能让我谈论这个重要的话题，我都会感到非常荣幸。所以谢谢你。是的，为了让我们的听众了解你是谁，以及为什么你要和我们谈论双相障碍，你能做一个简单的自我介绍吗？好的，我是萨姆。我之所以如此关心双相障碍，是因为我自己的亲身经历。当我18岁时，我……但最初花了几年的时间才得到那个诊断，这在我的青少年时期造成了一些困扰。但我非常非常幸运，遇到了那些愿意帮助我的人，他们在我心理健康方面给予了我支持。正因为如此，我非常非常感激。我想，对他们的感激让我意识到
that I wanna help others to be able to find the care that they need as well. So that very much inspired me to go down that route. So since then I've written my book, which is Winning the War with Bipolar, which is sort of a mixture of lived experience mixed with research on how you can manage this disorder, essentially. I'm now completing my PhD in bipolar disorder, specifically about cognition and functioning, which we can, I suppose, discuss
我想帮助其他人也能找到他们需要的护理。这极大地激励了我走上这条路。从那以后，我写了一本书，书名是《赢得与双相障碍的战争》，书中混合了我的亲身经历和关于如何管理这种障碍的研究。我目前正在攻读双相障碍的博士学位，专门研究认知和功能，我想我们可以在
later in the podcast. And also i run a small educational organization called scologists which uh helps in terms of hopefully inspiring the next generation of uh psychology students which is of course a great overlap with uh what you what you're very passionate in as well so yes an honor to be able to be alive for starters because I didn't always question I would be that but also hopefully to be a voice in this field and try to help it progress. Yeah thank you so much for for kind of doing such a good job on that and it sounds like a case of if you want something done ask a busy person like you sound really really busy um when it comes to bipolar diagnosis it's really common in my clinical experience that it happens much later than 18 um and I appreciate that you'd had some
播客稍后讨论。此外，我还经营着一个名为“Scologists”的小型教育组织，旨在激励下一代心理学学生，这当然与你非常热衷的领域有很大的重叠。所以，首先能活着就是一种荣幸，因为我并不总是确定自己能做到这一点，但同时也希望成为这个领域的声音，并努力推动它的进步。是的，非常感谢你做得这么好。这听起来就像是“如果你想完成某件事，就去请教一个大忙人”，你听起来真的很忙。在双相障碍诊断方面，根据我的临床经验，它通常发生在18岁以后，我理解你在18岁之前经历了一些
kind of perpetual struggles before 18 but actually for me as a health professional you know I'm pleased that you you got that diagnosis relatively early, but I appreciate it didn't perhaps feel that way to you. Yeah, I mean, it certainly is relatively early and relatively being the important word there, because, you know, when we think of that term, we think of in comparison to others. And I think, you know, I work considerably with Bipolar UK, they're sort of the main charity that I'm associated with and sort of support in terms of their work. And Bipolar UK found through the Bipolar Commission, which is a massive research project led by people from Cambridge and KCL and lots of top institutions, that it takes on average nine and a half years to get a diagnosis for bipolar. So, you know, for me, it was only a few since I was first diagnosed.
持续的挣扎，但作为一名健康专业人士，我很高兴你相对较早地得到了诊断，尽管我知道对你来说可能并非如此。是的，我的意思是，这确实相对较早，“相对”这个词很重要，因为当我们想到这个词时，我们是在与其他人进行比较。我想，我与英国双相障碍协会（Bipolar UK）合作很多，他们是我主要支持的慈善机构。英国双相障碍协会通过“双相障碍委员会”（由剑桥大学、伦敦国王学院等顶尖机构的研究人员领导的一个大型研究项目）发现，平均需要九年半的时间才能确诊双相障碍。所以，对我来说，距离我第一次被诊断才过了几年。
So I was lucky. But the sad thing is that I know for myself, had it taken nine and a half years, I'd be dead right now, because, you know, already that needs to be better. So in terms of the general field, but as to why I got an early diagnosis, that was, like I said earlier, because I was very fortunate to meet people that took me under their wing. So I was a research participant in research projects purely in the first instance because I wanted a bit of money. You know, I was not able to work because of my mental health. So I literally went to King's College to, OK, let's participate in this as an easy way to get a few pounds, essentially. And then and then it ended up meeting people who who helped me to get a diagnosis and then get the care that I needed. That's incredible. So you were initially trying to help yourself, but ended up helping yourself more than you could ever know.
所以我很幸运。但可悲的是，我知道如果当时花了九年半，我现在可能已经不在了，因为这方面确实需要改进。所以，就整个领域而言，至于我为什么能早点确诊，就像我之前说的，是因为我非常幸运地遇到了那些愿意帮助我的人。我最初参加研究项目纯粹是因为我想赚点钱。因为心理健康问题，我无法工作。所以我直接去了国王学院，想通过参与研究来赚点零花钱。结果，我遇到了那些帮助我确诊并获得所需护理的人。这太不可思议了。所以你最初是为了帮助自己，结果却得到了比你想象中更多的帮助。
And it's led to really useful stuff for other people to be helped as well. That's really, really powerful. For anybody that's listening to this as a total beginner they might have heard of bipolar before they might not even have heard of it before they might have previously heard of it under its previous name which used to be called manic depression but it was renamed um as bipolar disorder could you give us a very kind of whizzy quick whip through with what what is bipolar disorder sam yeah i'm i think i think you make a good point there that obviously before it used to be called manic depression and now that i think about it it's not really something i think about regularly but i think
这为其他人也带来了非常有用的帮助。这真的很强大。对于任何完全是初学者的听众来说，他们可能以前听说过双相障碍，也可能从未听说过，或者以前听过它的旧称“躁郁症”，但后来被更名为双相障碍。你能快速地为我们梳理一下，什么是双相障碍吗，萨姆？是的，我认为你提到了一个很好的点，即它以前被称为躁郁症，现在回想起来，我并不经常想到这一点，但我认为
almost it's actually a better name for the disorder sort of because bipolar is a word people use it in so many contexts they say for example that the weather it's a bit bipolar today or all of this type of thing or if someone has you know ups and downs in the mood in you know or in their emotions in a particular day they say oh you're acting very bipolar so there's a lot of myths and misconceptions around what people believe that this disorder is but in essence what bipolar disorder is is is having periods of low mood or depression and then periods of high mood or mania or hypomania so all it is is fluctuations of mood between extreme highs and extreme lows.
这实际上是该障碍的一个更好的名称。因为“双相”（bipolar）这个词在很多语境下都被人们使用，例如，他们会说“今天的天气有点双相”，或者诸如此类的话；如果某人在一天内情绪有起伏，他们会说“你表现得太双相了”。所以关于人们认为这种障碍是什么，存在很多误解。但本质上，双相障碍是经历低落情绪或抑郁期，然后是高涨情绪或躁狂/轻躁狂期。所以它只是情绪在极端高涨和极端低落之间的波动。
Human beings will experience highs and lows over different periods of time. It's just the human experience. We're not robots. But with individuals with bipolar, those extremes are more extreme than the average person. So you could view bipolar disorder essentially as a spectrum of mood. And essentially all human beings, I suppose, somewhere on that spectrum, it's just most people are not at the disorder level. So within bipolar disorder, you've got several different diagnoses. And you know, the classic case of the, I guess, the most severe in terms of the range of mood symptoms is bipolar type one disorder, where that is where you experience extreme highs in mood with what we call mania. And what mania is, is it's high mood so much so that it's causing significant impairment in terms of your functioning. So what I mean by that is often you're going to need to go into the hospital.
人类在不同的时期都会经历高潮和低谷。这只是人类的体验。我们不是机器人。但对于双相障碍患者来说，这些极端情况比普通人更极端。所以你可以把双相障碍本质上视为一个情绪谱系。我想所有人类都在这个谱系的某个位置，只是大多数人没有达到障碍的程度。在双相障碍中，有几种不同的诊断。你知道，在情绪症状范围方面最严重的经典案例是双相I型障碍，你会经历极度高涨的情绪，即我们所说的“躁狂”。躁狂是指情绪高涨到导致你的功能出现严重受损。我的意思是，通常你需要住院治疗。
You need to be hospitalized or, you know, at the very least, you're going to have significant problems in terms of your relationships and in terms of work. So it's going to cause basically a huge issue in terms of work. So it's gonna cause basically a huge issue in terms of your life. So what do those symptoms look like? So typically you're gonna not be able to sleep. So you might be able to get one to a few hours of sleep every single night, but you wake up with bounds of energy, a hundred times more energy than everyone else around you.
你需要住院，或者至少，你的关系和工作会遇到严重的问题。所以这基本上会给你的生活带来巨大的问题。那么这些症状是什么样的呢？通常你无法入睡。你可能每晚只能睡一到几个小时，但醒来时却精力充沛，比周围所有人多出一百倍的能量。
But that energy can be quite painful because you know when we think of a high energy state you know it's it's not just happy it's you know it can be very irritable or aggressive or you know very difficult to be able to manage it's too much energy in the same way with flights of uh, your thoughts are running so fast that it's too fast. Your thinking is overly positive that it becomes grandiose and you can believe things that aren't real and so on. And it can even cause sort of hallucinations and delusions. So the high mood of mania, I almost describe it as an incredibly high energy state and the reason why I say that is because when we have when we describe high mood we think
但这种能量可能非常痛苦，因为当我们想到高能量状态时，它不仅仅是快乐，它可能非常易怒、具有攻击性，或者非常难以管理。这能量太强了，就像思维奔逸一样，你的想法跑得太快了，快得过头了。你的思维过于积极，以至于变得自大，你可能会相信一些不真实的事情等等。它甚至可能导致幻觉和妄想。所以躁狂的高涨情绪，我几乎把它描述为一种极高能量的状态。我之所以这么说，是因为当我们描述高涨情绪时，我们认为
of it as wow that's a really positive thing you know you've got high mood that's great it's fantastic but you know it can get to that stage that is essentially it's more of an energy-based problem uh so you have this extreme highs of mood and then you crash into a depression so depression is the complete lack of energy or you know the incredibly low reason you know you might want to sleep a lot you might actually have problems with sleeping but you feel low energy uh you lack pleasure in your day-to-day activities and you struggle to find any satisfaction in your life so you know this huge high to this huge low you know is is essentially the characteristic of bipolar type one uh bipolar type two in terms of
这是一件非常积极的事情，你有高涨的情绪，这很棒，太棒了。但你知道，它可能会达到那种本质上更像是一种基于能量的问题的阶段。所以你有这种极端高涨的情绪，然后又陷入抑郁。抑郁是完全缺乏能量，或者极度低落。你可能想睡很多觉，或者实际上有睡眠问题，但你感到能量低落，在日常活动中缺乏快乐，难以在生活中找到任何满足感。所以，这种从巨大的高涨到巨大的低谷，本质上就是双相I型的特征。双相II型在
the severity of the extremities of going so high is less so because what you experience is something called hypermania which is where the form of mania is is not so severe that it's causing a significant impairment in your functioning you know you're able you're almost somewhat enjoying the process of the high and and it might not have a dramatic negative impact on your surroundings it might somewhat so for example you might spend recklessly and lose a lot of money you know you might go gambling and lose like all of your funds and everyone's very upset with you but um it's not going to lead to hospitalization or very, very severe negative consequences in your life. But the lows in bipolar type 2 tend to be longer.
极端高涨的严重程度上较轻，因为你经历的是所谓的“轻躁狂”，即躁狂的形式没有那么严重，不会导致你的功能出现严重受损。你几乎在某种程度上享受这个高涨的过程，它可能不会对你的周围环境产生巨大的负面影响，或者只有一点点。例如，你可能会挥霍无度，损失很多钱，你可能会去赌博并输掉所有的资金，每个人都对你很生气，但它不会导致住院或生活中非常、非常严重的负面后果。但双相II型的低谷往往持续时间更长。
And, you know, for that reason, it's not one of those things that you would view, you know, bipolar type 1 is a worse disorder than bipolar type 2. Instead, they're just different in terms of how the mood varies so you have you know in both you've got these highs and these lows and then you've got also other diagnoses that are you know lesser so in terms of the variance in mood but in general I suppose the main myth that is important to be busted is that, oh, your fluctuations in your emotions are like this every day. That means that you are bipolar. And typically in bipolar, it's long durations. So, for example, the highs have to be at least four days to a week, depending on the diagnostic criteria.
而且，出于这个原因，它不是那种你会认为“双相I型比双相II型更严重”的疾病。相反，它们只是在情绪变化方式上有所不同。所以，两者都有这些高潮和低谷，还有其他一些诊断，在情绪变化方面程度较轻。但总的来说，我认为需要打破的主要误区是：“哦，你的情绪波动每天都是这样，这意味着你是双相。”通常在双相障碍中，持续时间很长。例如，根据诊断标准，高涨期必须至少持续四天到一周。
And then the lows need to be at least a week or a couple of weeks. So you can have faster fluctuations, but you need to at least experience that to be able to get a diagnosis. So it's quite long periods of highs, long periods of lows. And then the goal essentially of treatment is to reduce the severity of that. So it goes from this to more like this.
然后低谷期需要至少持续一周或几周。所以你可以有更快的波动，但你需要至少经历这些才能获得诊断。所以这是相当长的高涨期和长期的低谷期。治疗的目标本质上是降低其严重程度。所以它从这样变成了更像这样。
Thank you so much for that kind of run through of what it is. And also you're giving some really good examples of how it might present. the more manic behaviors that lead to somebody becoming you know known to mental health services sometimes known to to justice services um sometimes taken to place of safety um because like you said sometimes they can be quite wild they can be um really quite impulsive you can feel like you're a millionaire you might you know giving all your money away or, you know, it's different for different people, but it always can look quite extravagant. well, lots of my clients have told me it feels pretty good to be in a manic phase when you're in it. But the fallout from it and the trauma and the impact on your professional life on your intimate family, friends life can be really, really catastrophic. Yeah. And that's the main thing like, you know, I think if you experience full-blown mania you realize that or you know similar states you realize that the negative consequences of that are almost higher than of depression
非常感谢你对它的梳理。你还给出了一些很好的例子，说明它可能如何表现。那些导致某人被心理健康服务机构所知，有时被司法服务机构所知，有时被带到安全场所的更躁狂的行为，因为正如你所说，有时他们可能非常狂野，非常冲动，你可能会觉得自己是百万富翁，你可能会把所有的钱都送人，或者对不同的人来说情况不同，但它看起来总是相当奢侈。嗯，我的许多客户告诉我，当你处于躁狂阶段时，感觉相当不错。但随之而来的后果、创伤以及对你的职业生活、亲密家庭和朋友生活的影响可能是非常、非常灾难性的。是的，这是最主要的事情。我认为如果你经历过完全的躁狂，你会意识到，或者类似的州，你会意识到其负面后果几乎比抑郁症还要严重。
the reason why is because depression you're an incredibly low state you know maybe you're suicidal you know it's terrible but the highs it's it's the impact it has on everyone around you. So, you know, it's the relationships that are lost. It's the money that's lost. It's the potentially whole life that's lost. You know, either you could die or maybe sadly end up in prison. Anything's really possible because it's just an obliviousness to the consequences of action so unless this is where the delusions the grandiose delusions come into it you know there's this thing so for example someone with mania they might believe okay i can jump off
原因在于，抑郁症时你处于极度低落的状态，也许你有自杀倾向，这很可怕，但高涨期，它对周围每个人的影响才是最严重的。所以，失去的关系、失去的金钱、可能失去的整个人生。你要么可能死亡，要么悲惨地最终入狱。任何事情都有可能发生，因为这只是对行为后果的无知。除非这就是夸大妄想发挥作用的地方，例如，患有躁狂症的人可能会相信“我可以从这个屋顶跳下去，我会飞”，因为你真的相信这一点，或者只是让自己陷入这些非常危险的情况。我的意思是，这……你可以死亡，所以这……我认为，但这……这太可怕了，我的意思是，说实话，在那种状态下几乎是不可能管理的，因为你处于一种无法管理自己行为的心态，因为一切都进行得太快了。感谢你与我们分享这些，这显然很有力量，而且它确实与你产生了共鸣，那种缺乏洞察力确实会导致你和其他双相障碍患者变得如此极其脆弱。在我早期的播客中
of this roof and i'll fly you know because you genuinely believe that or just get themselves into these sort of very dangerous situations i mean it's and you can you can die and so it's you know i thought but you know it's it's terrible i mean it's it's it's it's almost um impossible to manage to be honest in terms of that state you know is because you're in a state of mind that you're not able to manage you know your behavior because it's just everything's going too fast. Thank you for sharing that with us and it's clearly powerful and it really connected to you that idea that the kind of lack of insight can really lead you and other people with bipolar to be so incredibly vulnerable. And in one of my earlier podcast
我谈到了间接自残的概念，即某人并不一定想伤害自己。在低水平上，它可能是像啃手指上的皮，你知道，但实际上在极端水平上，它可能导致非故意的自杀，你知道，也就是意外死亡之类的。但这不是某人结束生命的意图，但有时确实会发生。人们是如此脆弱，不是吗？是的，他们是。而且家庭成员也值得在整个过程中得到很多支持和帮助，因为本质上每个人在那段时间都是脆弱的，这就是为什么避免这些发作非常重要。这就是为什么早期诊断极其重要。所以，通常在双相障碍方面，我的意思是，你会在你的临床实践中观察到，我相信你知道，在出现严重的躁狂情绪发作之前，会有一些倾向，某人可能容易
episodes of talking about the concept of indirect self-harm, which is where someone isn't necessarily meaning to hurt themselves. And on a low level, it might be something like nibbling the skin on our fingers, you know, but actually an extreme level, it can lead to not intentional suicide, you know, which is kind of death by misadventure or whatever. But it's not someone's intent to end their life, but it does sometimes happen. And that's people are so vulnerable, aren't they yeah they are and you know family members as well deserve a lot of support uh you know and and and help through the process because essentially everyone's vulnerable during that time which is the reason why it's it's very important to avoid those episodes and this is why early diagnosis is incredibly important so you know typically in terms of bipolar disorder i mean you know you'd you'd observe it in your clinical practice i'm sure you know there's there's inclinations prior to having a severe mood episode of mania uh that someone might be susceptible to be able to having
发生这种情况，并且可能涉及几件事。首先，可能是家族中有双相障碍，这可能是一件事，因为显然部分原因是遗传的。但同时，就以前的情绪发作而言，以前有过某种程度的高潮和低谷，只是没有达到那么严重的程度。正因为如此，从技术上讲，应该有可能尽早诊断，你可以防止如此严重的事情发生。这就是为什么诊断问题几乎是最重要的问题，因为这样你就可以获得正确的药物或一般的正确治疗，以便你能够更好地管理自己，这显然也涉及治疗。所以，是的，我会说防止躁狂负面影响的最好方法是首先防止它发生。是的，除了双相障碍的家族史之外，还有没有其他已知的先兆可能使某人更有可能发展成这种疾病？是的，我的意思是，肯定的。我的意思是，我们之前谈过创伤的概念以及双相障碍开始时的不同类型的创伤。我认为“创伤”这个词显然可以指几种不同形式的创伤。我的意思是，例如，头部受伤本身就可以增加患双相障碍的机会。所以对我来说，我头上有一道大伤疤，这道伤疤来自学校的一次伤害，那太可怕了，
that and there's several things that might be involved first firstly it might be bipolar in their family that might be one thing because obviously part of it is very much genetic but um you know also in terms of previous mood episodes you know previous periods of somewhat highs and lows you know but just not to that severe enough level and because of that you know technically it should be possible to be able to diagnose early and you can prevent such severe things happening and that's why the issue of diagnosis is almost the most important one to solve because you know then you can get on the right medications or the right treatments in general so that you're able to better manage yourself which also obviously involves therapy as well so yeah i'd say the best way to prevent the negative aspects of
那是一种操场事故。一个孩子推了我，然后我撞到了墙上，撞碎了，你可以看到我的头骨。所以那是一次非常严重的事故。我不确定这是否与我开始患双相障碍有关，那是之前的。但是，这很有可能。这有两方面。首先是创伤，
mania is to prevent it in the first place yeah and are there any kind of known precursors other than um other than family history of bipolar that might make it more likely that somebody would would develop that yeah i mean definitely i mean you know, we've talked before about the concept of trauma and different types of trauma within the beginnings of bipolar disorder. And I think that the word trauma obviously can mean several different forms of trauma. I mean, for example, head injury can increase the chances of bipolar disorder in itself. So for me, I've got this big scar on my head here, and this scar came from the injury in school in which it was horrible,
身体创伤，因为它是一次非常严重的伤害。但还有情感方面，因为那涉及欺凌，以及由此产生的很多焦虑，导致我在那里遇到了困难。所以，我认为这些事情肯定会导致易感性。我认为有很多遗传和环境的相互作用。但我也确实相信，我个人确实相信，非黑即白的思维也发挥了作用。所以我认为当我们有非黑即白的思维时，我们是在想：“好吧，这非常积极，这非常消极。”我们对事物有非常多的判断。
it was sort of a playground incident. A kid pushed me and then I went into the wall, smashed it, you could see my skull. So that was a very severe incident. And I'm not really sure whether that was linked to starting with my bipolar disorder that was previous to it. But, you know, it's very possible that that did. And there's two sides to that. Firstly, is the trauma, the
而且我确实认为，总的来说，拥有非黑即白的思维或在生命早期被教导这种思维，会导致状态分化的概念。因为在双相障碍中，显然它是两极的情绪障碍，本质上一切都是能量，或者一切都不是。所以这只是我个人的观点，我认为非黑即白的思维可能参与其中。例如，我是在一个非常宗教的家庭中长大的，作为耶和华见证人。我现在已经离开了这个信仰，但我确实相信，在一个确实在某种程度上促进对世界感知的极端的宗教中长大，是的，我认为它可能会增加这种机会。是的，你谈论有组织的宗教很有趣。公平地说，
physical trauma, because it was a very severe injury. But there's also the side of the uh sort of the emotional aspects of it as well because you know that was bullying associated and and and and a lot of i guess anxiety that resulted from that incident which which led to me uh sort of having difficulties there. So, you know, I think that those things definitely can sort of lead to susceptibility. I think there's a lot of genetic environmental interaction. But also, I do believe that, personally, I do believe that black and white thinking very much comes into play as well. So I think when we're having black and white thinking, we're sort of thinking, OK, very this is very positive. This is very negative. We very much judgments on things.
耶和华见证人是那样的吗？这是一种相当极端、有排他性和被排他体验的宗教。它非常多地将你和信仰中的人与外面的人分开。根据我与客户工作的经验，以及我自己上学的经历，我知道这实际上相当棘手，你在学校、校外、圣诞节、生日时必须把自己分开的方式，特别是如果你生活在西方世界，人们喜欢在你的生日给你买礼物，或者可能会邀请你参加他们的生日或圣诞聚会。当你不一定有选择去与众不同时，要与众不同是非常困难的。在你提到之前，我并没有真正意识到这一点。同样，对于创伤性
And I do think that in general, having black and white thinking or being taught it very early in life can can lead to the concept of of of uh differentiation of states because uh sort of in bipolar disorder obviously it's mood disorders of of extremities um at either side and essentially everything's all energy or everything's not so it's it's just a personal view that i think that black and white thinking can be involved uh and for example i was uh i was brought up um very religious uh as well as a jehovah's witness i've left the faith now but i do believe that being brought up in a religion that does sort of promote extremities somewhat in perception of the world. And yeah, I think it can sort of potentially increase the chances of that. Yeah, and it's interesting that you talk about kind of organized religion. Is it fair to say
脑损伤，你知道，我在2011年获得资格，我们现在是在2024年交谈。我在获得资格之前，甚至在培训期间，就有很多与创伤性脑损伤患者一起工作的经验，我不知道这会使你更有可能发展或可能发展成双相障碍。所以我认为这是这个播客和这类对话的真正力量，它教会了那些从业时间相对较长的人了解这些东西，但也多么不可思议，能够处于职业生涯的早期阶段，就已经知道这一点，并将其纳入你的雷达。嗯，我的意思是，谢谢。我认为从这个角度来看，我假设你，你知道，我不知道的事情有很多，但我猜我之所以知道我知道的事情，是因为亲身经历的混合，然后通过与我的上级交谈来试图理解和拆解这一点，他们对建立理解非常有帮助。但是的，我认为就创伤性头部损伤而言，你知道，这与患有双相障碍之间存在某种关系。然而，你知道，这显然不是人们倾向于患有它的主要原因。但是，是的，你提到的关于宗教的内容，我也认为，这种感到与他人不同的方面，我也认为，我们和他们这种思维，也可能导致任何类型的心理健康困难的产生。因为如果你感到与周围的人非常不同，
that that's what Jehovah's Witnesses is? It's religion that's kind of quite extreme and has the experience of othering and being othered. And it's very much kind of separating you and the people in the faith from people outside of it. And I know from my experience of working with clients, but also being in school myself, that actually that's quite tricky, the way that you have to kind of separate yourself in school, outside of school, around Christmas, around birthdays, you know, especially if you're kind of in a Western world where people like to buy you a present on your birthday or might invite you to their birthday or their Christmas gathering it's it's very difficult to be different when it's not necessarily your choice to be different and I hadn't really appreciated until you said and similarly with with traumatic
你知道，这会导致差距，而且这会让事情变得非常困难。所以我绝对认为，它会导致挑战。是的，这让我想到了贝塞尔·范德科尔克（Bessel van der Kolk）关于身体记录创伤的理论，你知道，你可能在当下能够从身体上度过非常具有挑战性的事情，但身体会识别并储存其中的一些，它可能会在以后的时间里表现出来。是的，我的意思是，我读过这本精彩的书。但是的，我会说，而且你感觉到了。我认为这是人们经历的事情，对吧？你知道，特别是当你经历生活中困难的阶段时，或者困难的事情，即使你记得它，你也会在身体里真切地感觉到。你
brain injury you know I've qualified in 2011 we're speaking in 2024 I've had many years of working even with people with traumatic brain injuries before I got qualified and during training I didn't know about that making it more likely that you would develop or could develop bipolar so I think this is the real power of this podcast and of conversations like this that it it teaches people who are relatively long in the tooth to know this stuff but also how incredible to be perhaps in a much earlier career stage and already know this and be aware of that and have that on your radar well well I mean thank you I think I think from from this perspective I suppose that you know there's a huge amount that I do not know but the reason the
可能会感到恶心。有些阶段，因为焦虑和与我所想的事情相关的其他事情，我感到需要呕吐。我认为身体确实吸收了它，我认为这与双相障碍也有很强的联系，因为它是一种能量状态。我真的很喜欢把它带回到能量，而不是情绪，因为你知道，本质上高能量，就像你在颤抖，你的腿不断移动，精神运动性激越，所有这些都与身体的能量有关。你知道，当你抑郁时，你几乎根本不动，你发现移动非常困难，你的大脑工作非常缓慢。所以我喜欢以这种形式思考它，而且我确实认为这与身体有非常强烈的联系。是的，绝对。我只是觉得
reason why I guess I do know the things that I do know is because of a mixture of lived experience and then trying to understand that and unpick that by talking to my superiors who who are very helpful in terms of building understandings but yeah I think in terms of you know traumatic head injury that you know there is sort of a relation between that and having bipolar disorder however you know uh you know it's not obviously sort of the primary reason as to why people people tend to have it but um yes what you mentioned as well regarding regarding religion i do think you know also this aspect of of feeling different to others i think that you know you know us and them type thinking is is can also lead to the generation of of of any type of mental health difficulty because if you feel very different to those around you
尽管我是一名经常与双相障碍患者一起工作的临床医生，但我还是学到了很多。所以，是的，也谢谢你。答案总是药物吗？总是终身服药吗？那里有什么选择？所以我们目前正在制作一篇论文，很快就会发表，关于双相障碍的自然病程。所以我们所说的自然病程是指，如果你去掉药物，双相障碍本身是什么样子的。我们这样做的方法是本质上查看那些没有服药的人的研究，或者比药物本身更早的研究。所以这是对双相障碍患者的一种分析。所以文献在对本质上所有这些研究的系统评价中发现，
uh you know it causes a gap and and and you know it makes things very difficult so I do definitely think um it causes challenges yeah and it's kind of making me think in terms of trauma of Bessel van der Kolk's stuff of the body holding the score you know that you might be able to get through things physically in the moment that might be very challenging but that the body will will kind of will recognize and will store some of that and it it might come out at later times yes I mean I was this fantastic book um but yes I'd say and you and you feel it I think I think that it's something that people experience right you know especially when you go through a difficult uh stage in your life and i you know or a difficult thing and even you remember it you literally feel in your body you
30%的双相障碍患者只会经历一次发作。通常那往往是躁狂发作。所以其他80%的人往往有相对复发的疾病，所以他们有再次发作的巨大风险，而且你知道，发作次数和频率有很大的差异。所以对于人们如何经历这种障碍以及发作是什么样子的，存在巨大的异质性或巨大的差异。对于双相障碍患者的最佳治疗方法也存在巨大的差异。所以，例如，如果你上网，例如在Twitter上，会有很多人强烈提倡改变饮食，例如，因为改变饮食帮助他们个人在双相障碍方面有所改善，他们强烈提倡这一点。而其他人则
might feel sick there are certain stages that i you know i feel the need to nearly throw up because of anxiety and things like that related to things i think that the body really does take it in and i think this sort of relates very strongly with bipolar disorder as well because it's an energy state i this is really why i like to bring it back to energy as opposed to mood because you know essentially high energy it's like you're shaking like your legs moving constantly psychomotor agitation all of these things relate to energy in the body you know when you're depressed you almost don't move at all you know you find it very difficult to move your brain is working very slowly so it's I like to think of it in that form and I do think that relates to sort of uh you know the body very much and very strongly yeah absolutely um I just feel
觉得药物对我来说才是关键，你是错的。你知道，你需要的是药物。然后其他人说只需要治疗，你不需要药物，你不需要改变饮食，你只需要治疗，这对他们有效。所以我认为在双相障碍中理解的重要一点是，虽然我们可以根据他们如何经历情绪将人们分类，但对于他们来说，最好的治疗方法、他们为什么患有这种疾病，存在巨大的差异，有很多不同的事情。而且个体之间的差异比其他地方的差异更大。所以一切都非常不同。
like I'm I'm learning a lot despite being a clinician that regularly works with people with bipolar. So yeah, thank you from me as well. Is the answer always medication? Is it always lifetime medication? What are the options there? So we're currently producing a paper, and it was soon to be published, regarding the natural history of bipolar. So what we mean by natural history is sort of what does bipolar look like in terms of the disorder itself if you take away medication and the way that we do that is by essentially looking at studies that are of people that aren't medicated slash studies which are older than the medications themselves so it's sort an analysis of individuals with bipolar. And so what the literature finds in a systematic review of essentially all of the studies on this
所以我个人认为，药物可能在最初阶段很重要，很可能，至少作为一种试图解决问题的方法，至少在短期内。原因是因为这是你能做的最快的事情。你知道，这是你能尝试的最快的事情。所以，你知道，就这一点而言，你服用一些药物，它会降低你进入进一步发作的可能性等等。但人们通过改变饮食和改变，以及单独进行治疗做得很好，这对他们有效。所以就药物而言，终身服用，我认为对于许多双相障碍患者来说，可能是大多数，但我不能确定这一点。我们谁都不能确定这一点。
is that 30% of people with bipolar disorder will only experience one episode essentially. And generally that tends to be a manic episode. So the other 80 percent tend to have a relatively recurrent illness so they have great risk of episodes coming back and you know there's great variance in in the number of episodes and how frequent they'll be so there's great heterogeneity or great variance essentially in how how people experience this disorder and what the episodes are like. There's also great variance in what is the best way of treatment for individuals with bipolar. So, for example, if you go online, for example, on Twitter, there'll be a lot of people heavily advocating for food changes, for example, because the food changes that help them as an individual to improve in terms of their bipolar disorder and they strongly advocate towards that uh whereas other people have
但至少很大一部分人可能需要终身服用。但关于治疗，这也是一个巨大的方面。这也是我在书中强烈讨论的内容。就治疗而言，还有CBT治疗。治疗的目标之一通常是在过程结束时创建一个治疗蓝图。那个蓝图，你正在构建这个过程，以便能够理解：“好吧，这是蓝图。这是我保持健康的方法。”通过遵循这一点，你可以防止未来的发作。这在治疗方面涉及什么？治疗在这方面的重要性是什么？它是什么，是你识别，
felt medication has been the thing for me you're wrong um you know it's it's uh it's it's medication that you need uh and then other people say only therapy you don't need medication you don't need to change food you just need therapy and it's worked for them so i think the important thing of understanding within bipolar disorder is that although we can categorize people in terms of these categories based on how they're experiencing their mood there's great variance in the best treatments for them why they have it so many different things and there's great variance in the best treatments for them, why they have it, so many different things. And there's more variance between individuals within the disorder than there are elsewhere. So everything's very different.
“好吧，我做什么来防止患双相障碍的可能性，对吧？防止双相障碍发作？我需要练习什么？”所以例如，那可能是，“好吧，我每晚在同一时间睡觉。我在那个时间服药。”显然，发作，我需要练习什么？所以例如，那可能是，“好吧，我每晚在同一时间睡觉。我在那个时间服药。”显然，我有生活，所以我必须尝试在某种程度上改变这一点，但在绝大多数时间里，我们尽量保持稳定，即使我睡不着，也可能待在床上，因为睡眠在这方面是一个巨大的因素。你知道，就饮食而言，尽量保持相对稳定。就药物或酒精而言，尽量远离。对不同的人有不同的策略，
So what I personally believe is that medication is probably important in the first instance, most likely, at least as a way to try to try to solve the issue essentially at least for the short term um the reason why is because it's the quickest thing you can do you know and it's the quickest thing you can try so you know in terms of that you know you take some medication uh you know it's going to decrease your likelihood of going into further episodes and so on. But people have done well with changing their food and changing their, and going to therapy alone, and that works for them. So in terms of medication though, having it for the lifetime, I think for a lot of individuals with bipolar disorder, probably the majority, but I can't be sure on that. None of us can be sure of that.
但你知道，基本上你制定了一个如何做到这一点的蓝图。然后你制定了一个蓝图，“好吧，早期症状，我们如何识别它们？它们什么时候来找我？你知道，这些症状是什么？”并识别那些早期症状，在它变成完全发作之前。因为那样你就可以做的事情是，例如，你知道，给精神科医生发信息，也许需要稍微改变一下药物，可能你需要改变生活方式中的某些东西，你知道，你可以做很多不同的事情。然后你在那个阶段阻止它。最后，如果你处于发作中，那么有另一个行动计划来处理它。但本质上，通过治疗的形式拥有这样一个过程，你能够做所有这些事情，显著降低了发生这种情况的可能性。
But a large proportion, at least, likely will need it for life. But regarding therapy, that's also a massive aspect of it. And it's something I discuss very strongly in my book as well. In terms of, you know, therapy, but also CBT therapy. One of the goals of the therapy generally is to create a sort of therapy blueprint by the end of the process. And that blueprint, you're building this process to be able to understand, okay, this is the blueprint. This is how I maintain my good health. And by following that, you can prevent future episodes. How does that involve in terms of therapy? What is the importance of therapy in this? What it is, is that you recognize,
但很大一部分人，至少很可能需要终身服药。关于治疗，这也是其中一个非常重要的方面。这也是我在书中重点讨论的内容。就治疗而言，不仅是普通治疗，还包括认知行为疗法（CBT）。治疗的目标之一通常是在疗程结束时制定一份治疗蓝图。通过构建这个过程，你可以理解：这就是我的蓝图，这就是我保持健康的方法。遵循这份蓝图，你就能预防未来的发作。这在治疗中是如何体现的？治疗在其中有什么重要性？其实质在于让你能够识别，
okay, what do I do to prevent the likelihood of getting bipolar disorder, right? Of getting a bipolar disorder episode? What are the things that I need to practice? So for example, that might be, okay, I go to sleep at the same time every night. I take my medication at that time. Obviously, disorder episode what are the things that i need to practice so for example that might be okay i go to sleep at the same time every night i take my medication at that time obviously i have a life so i've got to try to somewhat vary that but for the vast majority of the time we try to be you know solid with that even if i can't sleep potentially stay in bed because sleep is a massive one in terms of this you know in terms of food trying to be relatively stable in terms of you know drugs or alcohol trying the best to stay away where possible different strategies for different
好的，我该怎么做才能降低患双相情感障碍的风险，对吧？如何预防双相情感障碍的发作？我需要实践哪些事情？例如，可能是：好的，我每晚在同一时间睡觉。我在那个时间服药。显然，我也有自己的生活，所以我必须尝试稍微调整一下，但在绝大多数情况下，我们尽量保持规律。即使我睡不着，也尽量待在床上，因为睡眠对这一点至关重要。在饮食方面，尽量保持相对稳定。在药物或酒精方面，尽可能远离。针对不同的人有不同的策略，
people but you know basically you come up with a blueprint as to how to do that then you come up with a blueprint okay early symptoms how do we identify those when are they coming to me you know what what are these symptoms and and and recognizing those early symptoms before it becomes a full episode because then what you can do is for example you know message the psychiatrist maybe there needs to be a slight medication change it might be that you need to change sort of something in your lifestyle you know there could be several different things you could do. And then you stop it at that stage. And then finally, if you're in an episode, then having another action plan as to how you deal with that, but essentially having such a process through the form of therapy, that you're able to do all of these things significantly reduces the likelihood of having
但基本上，你会制定出一份如何做到这些的蓝图。然后，你会制定一份关于早期症状的蓝图：我们如何识别它们？它们何时出现？这些症状是什么？在症状演变成全面发作之前识别出它们，因为这样你就可以采取行动，例如给精神科医生发信息，可能需要稍微调整药物，或者可能需要改变生活方式，等等。你可以做很多不同的事情。然后你在那个阶段就阻止了发作。最后，如果你已经处于发作期，那么还要有另一份行动计划来应对。本质上，通过治疗形成这样一个过程，让你能够做到所有这些事情，将大大降低发作的可能性。
an episode. So whether that works in conjunction with medication or not. I think slightly depends like on the individual, there's going to be variation regarding that. But in my opinion, I think that for the most part, a mixture of medication and therapy is the best solution. Yeah. Thank you so much for that. That was so useful. And often when I'm talking with clients, I'll be like, actually, one of the things we need to do is
一集。所以无论这是否与药物结合使用，我认为这在一定程度上取决于个人，这方面会有差异。但在我看来，我认为在大多数情况下，药物和治疗的结合是最好的解决方案。是的。非常感谢你。这太有用了。通常当我和客户交谈时，我会说，实际上，我们需要做的事情之一是
to make life a little bit more consistent a little bit more predictable it might feel quite boring but actually it's the boring predictability that gives us all balance and actually certainly where there's been cases of kind of complex trauma you know growing up in kind of like chaos um things feeling unsafe there may never have been any structure or you know this is actually we have our dinner at this time we get up at this time you know we take our vitamins at this time of day like this literally you can be starting brand new afresh with that kind of basic what I would consider as a parent basic care that's what I do with my children I've got two of the beasts um you know but but for some people that's the first time ever that they've had that level of attunement and actually it can feel a little bit boring to begin with. But actually, when we know that actually we
让生活变得更规律、更可预测一些。这听起来可能很无聊，但实际上，正是这种无聊的可预测性给了我们所有人平衡。事实上，在某些复杂创伤的案例中，比如在混乱中成长，感觉不安全，可能从来没有任何结构，或者说，我们在这个时间吃晚饭，在这个时间起床，在这个时间吃维生素，这真的可以让你从头开始，用我所认为的父母的基本照顾方式。这就是我对待我孩子的方式，我有两个小家伙。但对有些人来说，这是他们第一次获得这种程度的协调，起初可能会觉得有点无聊。但实际上，当我们知道我们
exercise three times a week, or even if we just do it every day, and, you know, we have our dinner about six o'clock, and then we try not to drink much at night. So we're not having to wake up to have a wee, like, literally really, really boring things. And quite often with my clients with bipolar, we are literally going through the basics of how are you sleeping at the moment? Are you eating? Are you taking care of yourself? Are you getting out for those walks that we spoke about? And just keeping a track so that if there are, like you said at the beginning, natural fluctuations in mood, because we will have them due to grief, due to breakups, due to job changes, due to studying, you know, just due to the weather to due to breakups due to job changes due to studying you know just due
每周锻炼三次，或者即使我们每天都做，你知道，我们在六点左右吃晚饭，然后尽量晚上少喝酒。这样我们就不用为了上厕所而醒来，这真的是非常非常无聊的事情。通常对于我的双相情感障碍客户，我们实际上是在经历基础知识：你现在睡眠如何？你在吃饭吗？你在照顾自己吗？你有出去散步吗？我们只是保持追踪，这样如果像你开头说的那样，情绪出现自然的波动，因为我们都会因为悲伤、分手、工作变动、学习，你知道，仅仅是因为天气，因为分手，因为工作变动，因为学习，你知道，仅仅是因为
to the weather like there are natural fluctuations but it helps us to decide whether this is a fluctuation or whether this is actually a change in in kind of their bipolar state their presentation yeah and the consistency is just the most important thing. I mean, it's just, but there's something before consistency, I think, actually, now that I think about it. The thing before consistency is realizing that you don they want to chase the highs. Especially people, this is the reason why as well, I think that a lot of the time bipolar type two can actually be more of a trouble for people is because there's a lot of reason as to why to want the highs, because the highs don't have the same massive negative connotations as it could do with someone with bipolar one and you know there's a lot of reason to want that high you know you you have bounds of energy you've got all of
天气，会有自然的波动，但这有助于我们判断这是一种波动，还是实际上是他们双相情感状态或表现的改变。是的，一致性是最重要的事情。我的意思是，这只是……但在一致性之前还有一些东西，我想，现在回想起来。在一致性之前的事情是意识到你不想去追求那种高潮。特别是人们，我认为这也是为什么很多时候双相情感障碍二型实际上对人们来说可能更麻烦的原因，因为有很多理由想要那种高潮，因为这种高潮不像双相情感障碍一型那样有巨大的负面含义，你知道，有很多理由想要那种高潮，你有充沛的精力，你有所有
these great ideas you feel fantastic you're going around you're running around doing all of these things there might be some negative consequences but not massive ones so i think there's a lot and you know that's why people take drugs. Why do people take cocaine or methamphetamine is to get that same thing that people with bipolar disorder experiencing naturally. It's funny because a much older member of my family likely had bipolar disorder. But she often said, you know, people pay a lot of money to feel the way that i think that that i feel um so i think very much having this connotation that people pay money so you know to have such you know dopamine related drugs and you know yeah so so i think that's a big one and i
这些伟大的想法，你感觉棒极了，你到处跑，做所有这些事情，可能会有一些负面后果，但不是巨大的后果，所以我认为有很多……你知道，这就是为什么人们吸毒。为什么人们吸食可卡因或甲基苯丙胺，就是为了获得双相情感障碍患者自然体验到的那种东西。这很有趣，因为我家里一位年长得多的成员可能患有双相情感障碍。但她经常说，你知道，人们花很多钱去感受我认为我所感受到的那种感觉。所以我认为，这种认为人们花钱去获得与多巴胺相关的药物的含义非常重要，所以我认为这是一个很大的因素，我
think you've got to really realize okay this, this is not something that I want. This is not something that I want to continue in any way whatsoever. And from there, then decide, okay, I will do whatever I can to be able to have the life I want. do that is to realize that the best life is one that you can enjoy regularly you know and isn't so terrible the majority of the time like you know you want to have something you're not chasing short highs you have got a consistently good life and you can create a life for yourself. Like, you know, I was in a stage where a few years into, you know, my adulthood, I didn't really have a life and I didn't realize that, you know, there was some significant changes I needed to make to my mentality. Through making them, I've created a great life for myself.
认为你必须真正意识到，好吧，这不是我想要的。这不是我想要以任何方式继续下去的事情。从那里开始，然后决定，好吧，我会尽我所能去过我想要的生活。要做到这一点，就是要意识到最好的生活是你能够经常享受的生活，你知道，而且大部分时间不会那么糟糕。就像你知道的，你想要拥有一些东西，你不是在追求短暂的高潮，你拥有的是持续美好的生活，你可以为自己创造一种生活。就像，你知道，我处于成年后的几年里，我并没有真正拥有生活，我没有意识到，你知道，我的心态需要做出一些重大的改变。通过做出这些改变，我为自己创造了美好的生活。
You know, I've, you know, I'm married, I'm having a baby now, I've got not too much worries financially, I've managed to have created something quite cool. I'm finishing up my PhD. Obviously it's been hard work but it wouldn't have been possible if I hadn't realized that there's more to life than chasing a few moments of highs um so yeah I'd say that's the first one and then you know you've got to do that and then once you've done that then you're able to be consistent which is the best prevention essentially yeah so powerful and it's that idea of the highs may not be quite as high but the lows won't be as low and generally will have more
你知道，我结婚了，现在有了孩子，经济上没有太多担忧，我成功创造了一些很酷的东西。我正在完成我的博士学位。显然这很辛苦，但如果我没有意识到生活中不仅仅是追求那几个高潮时刻，那是不可能的。所以是的，我会说这是第一点，然后你知道，你必须做到这一点，一旦你做到了，你就能保持一致，这本质上是最好的预防措施。是的，太强大了，这种想法是高潮可能不会那么高，但低谷也不会那么低，通常会有更多
middle ground, more predictability, more consistency. And it actually reminded me of thinking about before I became a parent, actually, I probably had more highs that lasted for longer periods of time. But I would say there were also probably more lows that lasted for longer periods of time but I would say there were also probably more lows that lasted for longer periods of time you know if you became single or upset or you know oh I can't do this but generally speaking since becoming a parent even within any give you will you will learn soon even within any given day you might be having the worst day in the world with the child that's just not well that day or just really cranky and just screaming in your ear a lot but there will also in that same day be an incredible moment that just
中间地带，更多的可预测性，更多的一致性。这实际上让我想起在我成为父母之前，我可能确实有更多持续时间更长的高潮。但我会说，可能也有更多持续时间更长的低谷。你知道，如果你单身了，或者心烦意乱，或者你知道，哦，我做不到，但总的来说，自从成为父母以来，即使在任何一天，你很快就会知道，即使在任何一天，你可能和孩子度过了世界上最糟糕的一天，孩子那天不舒服，或者真的很暴躁，一直在你耳边尖叫，但在同一天里也会有令人难以置信的时刻，
like makes it all better but I think generally speaking having children has kind of given me more of that middle bound I haven't got a bipolar diagnosis but becoming a parent has given me more of that middle bound. I haven't got a bipolar diagnosis, but becoming a parent has given me more structure and given me more of the middle ground. Does that make sense? Definitely. And I think that this is where functioning becomes incredibly important, because this is a massive problem with treatments for psychiatric illnesses in general is that there's so much focus overall on symptom reduction and there's not enough on life boosting what i mean by life boosting is just you know increases in quality of life and how do we increase that is it's often by increasing your functioning so what i mean by that is how well are you functioning socially and occupationally and
让一切都好起来。但我认为总的来说，生孩子给了我更多那种中间地带。我没有双相情感障碍的诊断，但成为父母给了我更多的结构，给了我更多的中间地带。这有意义吗？当然。我认为这就是功能变得极其重要的地方，因为这是精神疾病治疗中的一个巨大问题，总的来说，重点太多在于症状减轻，而对生活提升的关注不够。我所说的生活提升是指生活质量的提高，我们如何提高它？通常是通过提高你的功能。所以我所说的功能是指你在社交和职业方面的功能如何，以及
in whatever way whatsoever you know there's multiple different domains of functioning but you know if you're able to improve in those things then your life can improve and you can be happy right uh so that's i think one advocate against um medication or being medication being the primary solution because medication can just up and up and up and up if that's the only way that you're treating it and you can end up you know getting out of bed you feel like a zombie type of thing so ideally you want to be on a medication that once you've stabilized on it you're able to actually live your life you're actually able to do things and you're actually able to to you know do the things that you want to do so that's why i think that treatments you know that's where therapy can come in as well i'm trained in a form of
以任何方式，你知道，有多种不同的功能领域，但你知道，如果你能改善这些方面，你的生活就能改善，你就能快乐，对吧？所以我认为这是反对药物或将药物作为主要解决方案的一个论点，因为如果这是你治疗的唯一方式，药物可能会不断增加，最终你会感觉像个僵尸。所以理想情况下，你希望服用一种药物，一旦稳定下来，你就能真正过上你的生活，你实际上能够做事情，你实际上能够做你想做的事情。所以我认为这就是治疗可以发挥作用的地方，我接受过一种形式的训练，
therapy called cognitive remediation which actually revolves around helping people to improve in their cognitive functioning and relating that to their occupational functioning. It's quite a simple form of therapy, it's not simple, it's simple from the therapeutic perspective because it's guided by sort of technologies online so you've got a digital world essentially. It's a digital world and you have real world related tasks that you as a therapist go through with the patient. And basically you go through it and try to help them
这种治疗被称为认知矫正，它实际上围绕着帮助人们改善认知功能，并将其与职业功能联系起来。这是一种相当简单的治疗形式，它并不简单，从治疗的角度来看它很简单，因为它是由在线技术引导的，所以你本质上拥有一个数字世界。这是一个数字世界，你有与现实世界相关的任务，你作为治疗师与患者一起完成。基本上你经历这些，并试图帮助他们
better problem solve through issues that they might relate in their personal life. And through that that they might relate in their personal life and through that they can build in their sort of strategy use which can then help them in terms of functioning in real life so I experienced that myself so I was sort of made yourself indispensable and I can see why you're obviously very good at what you do and thank you for speaking you know so openly and honestly to help our audience to learn more about this if people want to learn more about you and your book where should they go um so my book's on amazon you can look up winning the war with bipolar uh so for you know and then
更好地解决他们在个人生活中可能遇到的问题。通过这种方式，他们可以建立自己的策略使用，这可以帮助他们在现实生活中发挥作用。所以我自己也经历过，所以我被塑造成不可或缺的人，我明白为什么你显然非常擅长你所做的事情，感谢你如此开放和诚实地帮助我们的听众更多地了解这一点。如果人们想更多地了解你和你的书，他们应该去哪里？嗯，我的书在亚马逊上，你可以搜索《赢得与双相情感障碍的战争》，所以你知道，然后
through that you can find other things that i'm doing online. But yeah, my book, I'd say, is been mostly enjoyed by clinicians, funny enough, and sort of people who are sort of researchers. But it's very useful for people as well with lived experience, because it sort of goes through, I guess, four steps very much related to funny enough, what we've been talking about the first one being understanding what is bipolar disorder in terms of you know understanding that in depth then about how can you make the most of therapy and psychiatric relationships following that is sort of self-care strategies and then finally consistency so that's sort of the four sections
通过那个，你可以找到我在网上做的其他事情。但是的，我的书，我想，有趣的是，主要是被临床医生和研究人员所喜爱。但它对有生活经验的人也非常有用，因为它经历了四个步骤，非常有趣，与我们一直在谈论的内容相关。第一步是理解什么是双相情感障碍，深入理解它，然后是如何充分利用治疗和精神科关系，接下来是自我护理策略，最后是一致性，所以这就是书的四个部分，
of the book so it's quite a good if I say so myself way of sort of going through the the sort of stages of bipolar brilliant well how how on brand was I today as a host for for guiding people through just why your book is such a brilliant read thank you for your time I know that we are connected on LinkedIn is that a good place for people people to come and follow you and kind of learn more about your work as well? Yeah, yeah, LinkedIn as well. That's where I mostly am. Okay, could you spell your surname or spell your full name for us in case people are listening as an MP3 rather than watching on YouTube? Yeah, so it's Samuel, so S-A-M-U-E-L, and my surname S-W-I-D k i perfect samuel swidzinski thank you so much and um yeah just thank you again i know that this will help so many people and just before we finish if somebody's listening to us and thinking that they're concerned about their own mental health
所以如果我自己说的话，这是一个很好的方式来经历双相情感障碍的各个阶段。太棒了，作为主持人，我今天在引导人们了解为什么你的书是一本如此出色的读物方面做得多么到位。感谢你的时间，我知道我们在领英上建立了联系，那是人们来关注你并更多地了解你的工作的好地方吗？是的，是的，领英也是。我大部分时间都在那里。好的，你能为我们拼写一下你的姓氏或全名吗，以防人们是在听MP3而不是在YouTube上观看？是的，是Samuel，S-A-M-U-E-L，我的姓氏S-W-I-D-Z-I-N-S-K-I。完美，Samuel Swidzinski，非常感谢你，再次感谢你，我知道这会帮助很多人。在我们结束之前，如果有人在听我们说话，并认为他们担心自己的心理健康，
and that actually bipolar makes a lot of sense for them or someone else that they care about what should they do so first off i mean bipolar uk is a fantastic organization so um bipolar uk who have worked with extensively have a e-learning package they've also got a new tracker app and they've also got uh sort the Could It Be Bipolar campaign. If you look up Bipolar UK and then Could It Be Bipolar, let's say that's got a good starting place, you can learn a little bit more so that you might get a better understanding. You'll see my face pop up a couple of times. But in terms of that sort of good grounding, then download the Guru Tracker app, try to figure out, just find out whether, you know, you think that your mood is high. And, you know, clinicians here in the UK have been told about Bipolar UK.
并且实际上双相情感障碍对他们或他们关心的其他人很有意义，他们应该怎么做？首先，我的意思是，英国双相情感障碍协会（Bipolar UK）是一个很棒的组织，所以我与他们广泛合作过，他们有一个电子学习包，他们还有一个新的追踪应用程序，他们还有一个“这可能是双相情感障碍吗？”活动。如果你搜索Bipolar UK，然后搜索“Could It Be Bipolar”，这是一个很好的起点，你可以多了解一点，这样你可能会有更好的理解。你会看到我的脸出现几次。但就那种良好的基础而言，下载Guru Tracker应用程序，试着弄清楚，找出你是否认为你的情绪很高。而且，英国的临床医生已经被告知了Bipolar UK。
And if you bring in the Mood Tracker app, you know, there's something that you can discuss with the clinicians or your doctor in general. And that can sort of support a diagnosis, I suppose, earlier. I think as well, to be honest, the best thing that you can do, I realise not everyone watching is actually watching sort of a video of us. Essentially, what you can do is get a piece of paper and you can plot out your mood over time. So what that looks like is sort of, it's impossible to describe if someone's not watching, but you've sort of got a, you know, a typical, you know,
如果你带上Mood Tracker应用程序，这是你可以与临床医生或你的医生讨论的事情。这可以在某种程度上支持更早的诊断。老实说，我认为你能做的最好的事情是，我意识到并不是每个人都在看我们的视频。本质上，你可以做的是拿一张纸，随着时间的推移绘制你的情绪。所以它看起来像，如果有人没在看，很难描述，但你有一个，你知道，一个典型的，你知道，
a graph and in the middle is sort of... Like an xy axis. Yeah and in the middle of it is sort of a stable mood and then you plot over time on the x-axis. So when has your mood been really high? When has it been low? And then that's a good starting point to discuss with the clinician. This is what my mood has looked like over time. And that can sort of help them to understand the picture and sort of guide them through why bipolar might be a particular diagnosis. And then they can use that as a guide as to how to say okay what was it like during this period can you explain how you were can you
一个图表，中间是……就像一个XY轴。是的，中间是稳定的情绪，然后你在X轴上随时间绘制。那么你的情绪什么时候非常高？什么时候很低？然后这是一个与临床医生讨论的好起点。这就是我的情绪随时间的变化。这可以帮助他们理解情况，并引导他们了解为什么双相情感障碍可能是一个特定的诊断。然后他们可以以此为指南，说明好吧，这段时间是什么样的？你能解释一下你是怎么样的吗？你能
explain how you're acting so you're you're almost guiding them through the process of of of your mood so that they can professionally be able to to actually unpick whether they think that you've got the disorder great thank you and obviously if anybody's concerned about the risk to themselves or someone else they should contact urgent care or emergency services to safeguard them or other people. Thank you so much Sam it's been a really really brilliant episode and thank you please let me know if you need anything in future. No worries at all it's been great to chat. Thank you. Oh gosh, how incredible it was to chat with Sam. And if you do want to connect with Sam or have a look at his book, please do check out the details in my show notes. Like I said to Sam, it was a real privilege to talk with
解释一下你的行为吗？所以你几乎是在引导他们完成你的情绪过程，这样他们就能专业地分析他们是否认为你患有这种疾病。太棒了，谢谢。显然，如果有人担心对自己或他人的风险，他们应该联系紧急护理或紧急服务部门以保护他们或其他人的安全。非常感谢你，Sam，这是一集非常非常精彩的节目，谢谢你，如果将来有任何需要，请告诉我。不用客气，聊天很愉快。谢谢。天哪，和Sam聊天真是太不可思议了。如果你想和Sam联系或看看他的书，请查看我节目说明中的详细信息。就像我对Sam说的那样，能和他交谈真是我的荣幸，
him and I learned so much. Has this been useful for you? If so, please do rate and review the podcast series, which you can do on Apple Podcasts. You can also rate it on Spotify. If you're watching on YouTube, please do take a moment to subscribe to the channel, like the content and fling some comments around to perhaps share your favorite episodes with your friends. Come and let me know in the aspiring psychologist community, which is the home of the exclusive Marianne's Motivation and Mindset videos. You will not get them anywhere else. Come and join the free Facebook group and I will look forward to seeing you there. New episodes of Marianne's Motivation and Mindset drop every Friday morning. And each of these podcast episodes is available to you on YouTube, you lucky things, from 10am on Saturdays with new audio podcasts wherever you get your podcasts available from
我学到了很多。这对你有用吗？如果是这样，请给播客系列评分和评论，你可以在Apple Podcasts上进行。你也可以在Spotify上评分。如果你在YouTube上观看，请花点时间订阅频道，点赞内容，并发表一些评论，也许可以与你的朋友分享你最喜欢的剧集。来有抱负的心理学家社区告诉我，这里是独家“玛丽安的动力与心态”视频的所在地。你在其他任何地方都找不到它们。快来加入免费的Facebook群组，我期待在那里见到你。新一集的“玛丽安的动力与心态”在每周五早上发布。每一集播客都会在周六上午10点在YouTube上为你提供，幸运的家伙们，音频播客可以在你获取播客的任何地方从
6am on Mondays. Do come and connect with me on my socials. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. Consider having a read of the books, The Aspiring Psychologist Collective, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and of course, Talking the Aspiring Psychologist Collective, the Clinical Psychologist Collective, and of course, Talking Heads and the Grief Collective too. And if it's your time and you're ready for the next step, you're ready to get, really get a grip on making your professional career in psychology sparkle in this upcoming application season,
周一早上6点开始获取。一定要在我的社交媒体上与我联系。我到处都是Dr. Marianne Trent。考虑阅读这些书：《有抱负的心理学家集体》、《临床心理学家集体》，当然还有《Talking Heads》和《悲伤集体》。如果你准备好了迈出下一步，准备好真正掌握让你的心理学职业生涯在即将到来的申请季中闪耀，
please do consider joining the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which you can do for no minimum term from just £30 a month. I am so blessed to have you to be part of my world and I will look forward to catching up with you very soon. Take care. and let this be your guide. With this podcast, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist, it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this
请考虑加入“有抱负的心理学家会员”，你可以以每月仅30英镑的价格加入，没有最低期限。我很幸运能拥有你成为我世界的一部分，我期待很快与你联系。保重。让这成为你的指南。有了这个播客，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是Dr. Marianne Trent的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我叫Jana，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣，我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，而且没有完美的途径可以成为一名临床心理学家。这
kind of filled me with confidence that no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
让我充满了信心，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你感到安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。